i must say i was sitting at home pining
for you last week
i
fought i wanted to make sure we had
church
and i pushed and pushed and pushed but
they finally said you don't want anyone
to die just to come to church do you
well i said it's pretty close
i love having church it's great to have
you here i know for some of you this is
a very strange experience uh i remember
going to my first church service in
college uh i had been born and raised in
el paso texas i had gone to the same
church my whole life
and the first sunday i was at college i
went off to this little methodist church
in amherst massachusetts
and i went there and it was so totally
unfamiliar and strange and i didn't know
anybody and these were my you know my
parents my grandparents my adopted
grandparents the kids i'd gone through
sunday school with my whole life
and suddenly i was in a church that
didn't feel like church at all
and so i
i ask you to just give it a chance
give it a chance to get over that first
moment of discomfort that things are a
little different these are wonderful
people here you've already seen a lot of
them you'll meet a lot more of them
stay for lunch after church that's the
best way to meet people we're going to
have lunch up here right after church
then we're going to right after that
we're going to make
lunches for the homeless out on the
green
so it's a big day
and so we encourage you to just give it
a chance stay and get to know us
it's a great church
what kind of church is it people always
ask me what label do i put on it i have
no idea
what kind of church are we
we're unlike any church i know we're
historic
but we're brand new
we're in yale but we're also in new
haven
we're academic but we're as much focused
on the heart we hope as on the head
we're traditional but we're contemporary
uh we do
people ask me well do you have organ do
you have guitar do you have drums do you
have choir and i say yes
we have everything
we're global but we're local
most of all i think we're unmistakably
christian but integrating many
perspectives on how to live following in
jesus's footsteps
uh we're a community that reflects yale
that tries to speak to your experience
as people in an academic community
and most of all we want your questions
so if after this service you think why'd
they do that
you have questions about anything to do
with your life of faith in this place we
welcome all those questions
so i was thinking about these texts for
the first sunday you heard them all
jeremiah romans and matthew
and i thought couldn't we have nicer
texts for the first sunday
couldn't we have happier
welcoming texts and romans certainly
does a good job romans is all about good
good messages it's that part at the end
of all the epistles where
paul says all those nice things about
what we should do but the jeremiah is
all about how tough it is to stay close
to god's word and then the matthew is
all about take up your cross and follow
me
and i thought this is not the way to
preach the first week
you notice i took off my watch
richard was telling me earlier he
notices that i do this
he notices it most because i put it down
here and then i never look at it again
i have a friend
folks have heard me say then keva
senpangi from uganda and he would always
say
in africa
we preach
till we are done
i promise not to do that today
i know you have the bizarre to get to
and things
but i thought what better week to give
you something with meat
something sorry vegetarians vegans
something with substance
what better week to give you something
with substance than these texts which
say that it's not always going to be
easy we're not the kind of church that
will attract you in with fun
and with happy music and everything and
then suddenly spring all the hard stuff
on you that's not the way we do it we
want you to get the whole gospel
and that includes some tough things and
some easy things some joyful things and
some hard things because living the life
of faith is not easy
but it is
joyful
so we're in this story in the gospel
and i think it helps us with decisions i
think that's what this is about this
story of peter and jesus in this
dialogue about jesus is predicting his
coming passion and peter says no no no
that should never happen
and then
jesus says
you
are satan
to peter we don't get that part very
often and nobody emphasizes that but he
has hard words for peter because he says
you're thinking the wrong idea about
what i came to preach
and then he goes on to talk about how we
live this life
about how
we have to lose this life
in order to gain it
how we can't gain the whole world and
lose our own souls
and i thought what better message for
the start of your experience at yale
than
the fact that you're going to have to
make some decisions about what life you
want to lead
and it's not just the freshman yesterday
at the deakins retreat we had a deacon's
retreat all day yesterday at my house
and seniors were discussing jobs and
what decisions they were going to make
about jobs grads were discussing post
docs
people were talking about what was going
to happen to them in the future and it's
always a good time to ask even for those
of us who've been here for a long time
what does it mean
to follow jesus of nazareth
at this point in my life
we're often in lots of habits that we're
well used to it's always good to ask
what do i need to do to follow jesus of
nazareth right now
and i want to tell a story that i'm not
sure fits
but i'm going to give it a try
and it's a story about my life which i
always hesitate to do
i don't want to
use this as therapy that's really
terrible preaching
but i remembered in this story as we
hear about jesus saying you need to lose
your life to get it
i was thinking about that word about
losing your life and what's entailed in
that
how that counter-cultural that is
yale is all about getting hold of your
life right
it's about holding tight
it's about a plan to get me through to
the very end it's about achievement it's
about success it's about that seven
seven-figure salary right
it's about
control it's about a vision
and here jesus says nope
in order to get a hold of your life at
all you gotta give it up
oh so unyail
so it's worth
thinking about and it reminded me of
this story about when i was a senior
at amherst college just up the road and
i was writing my honors thesis
and they gave me a carol in the library
a little
place with a desk and a chair and it was
back on level a
which was down in the basement it was
the ugliest part of the library it's
just cinder block walls all around me
and my little carol little black metal
carol with the desk and a chair
and i was researching my honors thesis
my senior essay on eschatology and
social ethics in the monasticism of
saint basil the great
really exciting and relevant topic
but i loved it
but so i was down there paging through
these dusty greek tomes every night you
know for hours trying to get my thesis
done
and on my carol they gave me a little
white tag
it was a little adhesive tag like an
address tag and you went in at the
beginning of the year and as a senior
you had the privilege of going around
and selecting a carol and putting your
tag on it this was a big deal it'd be
like having a carol and bass of your own
or something like that
so i went and put my tag that was my
spot i had all my dusty tomes up there
and i worked and worked and worked and
it was no fun but
you know it got done
and one day i guess it was march or
april
i came into my little carol and i was
opening up my huge greek book
and i looked up at my little tag and
where i had my name it said ian oliver
someone had written above it in pencil
loser
and i was hurt
i was deeply hurt by this
everyone loves me right
i'm you know who could say such a thing
about me i'm you know i'm successful in
school i'm headed for phi beta kappa i'm
headed for high honors i've got
acceptance at graduate school
everyone loves me
who could say this about me
and it it did hurt me at a level i don't
think i've told anybody about this
since then
it hurt me that deeply no i know i told
one person a little later
but i didn't say it broadly because i
really hurt me because i was a high
achiever
i wanted my life to be a success and i
wanted everyone to love me i had a
little bit of what we call around here
the imposter complex
that sense that everybody else at my
college got in because they were smart
and beautiful and wonderful and i got in
by accident
that the forms got scrambled one day and
they let me in but it was totally a
mistake
uh and that was the impression i had and
it can i'm sure it can be that way at
yale sometimes too
so i had this impression and i thought
uh somebody's finally figured me out
and they see beneath this veneer of my
life
of success and confidence and high
office and rewards and everything else
and they see who i really
am a loser
how does it go like this right
i can't remember
and
a few well i guess it was about a month
later
i was getting involved in a relationship
with someone i thought was absolutely
wonderful
and i ventured to tell them my deep dark
secret about the loser written on my tag
and this wonderful person who i still
love
said to me
said
yes
you are a loser
it was not what i wanted to hear
said you are a loser
but you're the loser
i love
that's what jesus is saying to us today
you're the loser
i love and you can only claim my love
if you lose this life
and accept me
lose all the things you think about
yourself all the stories you tell
yourself about who you are because other
people have told you who you should be
lose all the voices in your head your
parents your friends the people on your
hall they're telling you what kind of
person you should be
lose all your ambitions sorry to say
parents don't listen
lose all those ambitions that tell you
again who are you who are you who are
you everyone is telling you
what jesus is saying is lose those
voices
and listen to me
i'll tell you who you are
you
are the loser
i love
i know this is weighty stuff for the
first sunday
but there are choices you're going to
make here at yale and the biggest one is
choosing whose life you're going to live
here
and there are two choices one you can
live the life of your fears
the fear of being discovered the fear of
being an imposter always afraid of what
other people might think
always afraid that people might discover
who you really are
always afraid of falling behind always
afraid someone else will expose you or
hate you or destroy you
but the other choice is
if i don't choose the life of my fears
is to choose the life god wants for me
if i'm willing to lose the life of my
fears for the sake of god i will gain
the life that god wants for me but the
only way to lose that fearful life is to
let go and take the risk of following
jesus wherever he goes
and that means no plans oh my planners i
love you i love you all
you're all planners i know
jesus is saying
give it up
your plans are important your success is
important all that but it only comes
after you give up your control
then you can accept
the path that god gives you the success
that god gives you but as long as you
think that success and that path are
going to save you it's going to eat you
alive
so you got to let it go
and god will give you love and grace and
hope and comfort and community and
purpose that you never imagined
weird ideas from totally outside your
brain will suddenly pop in
that will say go there and do this
go help those people that i love
remember that i love you
have the courage to talk to that person
that you think you love
follow a new path
jesus says this life
this life for me
is not the life i tell myself about
there's something bigger than me
there's something bigger than what me
can achieve there's something more solid
and stronger than me there's something
that could survive the destruction of me
in fact a me is there that can only be
borne by losing the old me
and getting a new me
we are the losers
jesus loves
losers gather together in a beautiful
place
to celebrate our shared loss
and the new lives
we are gaining
amen